a swarm of bodies filled central London
this the biggest protest the capital has
seen since the rally against the Iraq
war they want another referendum on the
UK's decision to leave the government to
sisyas some notices because she keeps
talking about the people have spoken and
I feel completely unlimited to divide a
country all the ways we could come back
together it's by having a proper debate
about again it would lead to more
division another referendum another big
question to the people I don't think
talking about the issues can lead to
more divisions talk about it is the way
we resolve it in this country that's
democracy isn't it what do you say that
52 percent of people voted to leave 52
per squat a percent to that fifty
percent even now no one knows what
breaks it is a mess we were supposed to
be leaving the EU next Friday but with
Parliament refusing to back the Prime
Minister's negotiated withdrawal
agreement uncertainty continues to rain
next week MPs are expected to be given
the chance to indicate what they think
should happen next
we've already had votes on all of these
things they've all been rejected all
these Norway options customs union
options we've we've discussed these
things ad nauseam actually and at the
end of the day the only votes that
matter are the the vote of the people to
leave in the referendum you couldn't
imagine Nicola Sturgeon getting this
reception in London if she was here to
express her views on Scottish
independence politicians from all
spectrums came to the stage perhaps most
significant Labour's deputy leader who
said he'd support Mays deal on one
condition
[Applause]
Tom Watson backing of people's vote when
Jeremy Corbyn remains undecided
these protesters know the Labour leader
is crucial to achieve their back to the
test
however in beastin a group of pro brexit
campaigners gathered outside a pub to
counter claims that anything had changed
in how the british public feels about
the EU this is now a battle of people
versus the politicians for the first
time in the history of our great country
we have a parliament ignoring the will
of the people it's a betrayal it's a
total disgrace both sides agree on one
thing the government has failed this was
the London protesters reaction as they
passed Downing Street
[Music]
but Teresa may wasn't there she's in
checkers contemplating her next move
amid speculation that it may be calling
time on her leadership if she can't get
her deal through next week
Jason Farrell Sky News